plus de 700 places d'hébergement
d'urgence ont été ouvertes en indre et
loire cet hiver pour les sdf
mais pour des raisons diverses certains
dorment encore dehors au parc de la
gloriette le plus grand de l'agglo
quatre d'entre eux vivent ainsi dans un
campement de fortune
problème la métropole veut aujourd'hui
les expulser elle invoque des raisons de
sécurité lucas chopin le soleil est levé
sur tours le thermomètre affiche de
petits degrés elie rigobert ne vit pas
dehors mais presque depuis neuf mois
il occupe un camp de fortune dans le
parc de la gloriette masse est ainsi en
fait on se lève à peu tard parce que bon
on profite de la cabane pour être un peu
plus au chaud justement voilà des fois
en trente portant dormir pourtant son
quotidien il ne le voit pas ailleurs
l'homme de 31 ans occupe avec trois
camarades ce terrain privé qui
appartient à la métropole
aujourd'hui on leur demande de quitter
les lieux
ce qu'il refuse il a même écrit à la
préfète d'indre et loire
je lui ai expliqué que voilà on était
sur le terrain de la gloriette depuis
avril et que
et que là on était en procédure
d'exclusion que on avait des chiens
qu'on ne voyait pas aller dans les
logements sociaux pour pour que nos
chiens se retrouve en cage
ouais on ne voyait pas non plus côté une
maison abandonnée pour faire jeter ans
au printemps
contactée la direction du parc explique
avoir été clémente et avoir privilégié
la médiation avec l'assistance de l'aide
sociale la présence de deux gros chiens
inquiète pour la sécurité des promeneurs
et les sans domiciles fixes vont devoir
partir pour autant et lee souhaite
rester le plus longtemps possible
on va certainement se prendre une prune
on va tellement certainement faire virer
mais au moins ce qu'on a fait on l'a
fait de nos mains et ben s'il faut en
passer par là bas on ne passera par là
c'est comme ça et puis on recommencera
et puis voilà
sans évolution de la situation la
métropole de tours engagera
prochainement une procédure auprès du
tribunal administratif